[Music]
made mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey guys welcome to D LM model
lifestyle I'm Daniel Desmond brother
happening hey you guys have been
following us for the last series of the
body transformation from fat to fit know
that this is our last two weeks so far
have no loss around 18 kilos I think we
started at around 100 he's now at eighty
two point seven kilos we only have two
weeks left so I know what the diet plan
the work of the team what are we gonna
do because we want to win this
competition such a goal so the goal is
minimum of 20 I think it would be much
better if we can be around 22 which
makes the goal for the last two weeks
around five guys so that's a good five
guys okay so all of all we also want to
focus on the gaining a bit of muscle and
definition as well so that's about seven
outside seven guys of fat loss that's a
lot yeah yep okay so nutrition what
we're gonna do is well for the protein
we're gonna rely on this baby okay use
any there's a bunch of other plants how
they there's a bunch of other different
formulas and things but we're gonna
practice on this dish a guys now is not
a sponsored video but I happen to he has
to use the US and products for the body
makeover challenge competition that he's
doing I like muscle tech for example
we'll add a few options bring the video
description as well but let's continue
you can you know so why we chose this
baby it's got cute amount of protein it
is about 25 pounds per serving or
serving it's gonna be a huge list of
vitamins and minerals solution some
things yeah another good thing is it's
got some garnet in here as well but its
output
that's metabolism this so with protein
we're going to supplement this lot with
some good vegetables
yeah it's broccoli and stuff like that
so get a lot of nutrients in there that
would actually help us to lose some
weight
okay yeah so not a lot of cops are cops
out there sugar of course alright but
anyway that was last week so we have to
look forward all right so that's we're
gonna bring that in we're still gonna do
the intermittent fasting focus on eating
for hours and 28 hours just a fasting
right and anything else you want to have
the plan yeah that's beef balancing act
we don't want to go too much we don't
want to go too little we just wanna keep
in that sweet spot yeah and we'll we'll
see how my body feels if you feel we
need a bit more energy we'll wrap it
with more effects if we feel enough
energy we won't even eat for that time
right yeah so yeah so the guys nutrition
yeah
we're also going to use a little bit a
pre-workout maybe some intro workout in
the post-workout we'll use the the whey
protein but as you guys know for this
whole process had an adapted to new
healthy lifestyle and so it was the last
video you guys saw that I give him the
power to change the diet plan workout
routine to fit in with his life's done a
little bit better because he did the
research right
so it's kind of proof that you can
change to a healthy lifestyle if you
have five kids you have work schedule
that's changing all the time yeah you
know what I was thinking mmm-hmm so the
big thing we were were sighing and
everybody sign is he news white in the
kitchen yeah we get to fit in the gym
yeah but I I actually used to think it's
another thing to get healthy first in
your mind
mmm I say that so change your perception
of what what you take in what you do and
so on actually that is that is very good
a lot of people asked what is the best
diet out there or the best diet is the
one that you can stick to the one that
mentally you can stick to and you can
change to a healthy lifestyle not
changing to a new diet plan every now
and then but okay so the workout routine
what we're gonna do there the last two
weeks we gotta go hard for yeah well we
said we lost a lot of time and a lot of
the previous two weeks so we need to
make up for that yeah if we don't do
that if we don't put enough intensity
and time into the workouts to add to
what we're doing with the nutrients
we're not gonna make it
so how you're gonna fit it in then so
the first thing is of course time and
schedule it okay so every second counts
there's no sick there's not a minute of
idling around so even alone we need to
get started structured quality time with
the family we need to do that we need to
get the kids in the bed soon enough we
need to get that aside at seven at least
I also sleep in for recovery time we
don't have that we don't have anything
and lost and we need to wake up soon
enough
hit the cardio get the cardio heart go
to work and then after noon we need to
get in the to the gym be prepared for
going into the gym beforehand so that we
don't get all that all around me to get
into gym do what we need to do big thing
this time around as well is we need to
make sure that we do a better walk just
make sure that we don't hit anything
hmm so if we make any mistakes try
something where as a muscle we're done
for as well so there's no breathing
spice in your no revenue no mistakes
it's not just about doing one thing
right us but doing all these things
right having this perfect balance of
eating clean working out consistently
getting enough sleep drinking enough
water all these things come together
into play right so shall we take them to
the gym show you guys the workout let's
eat the gym let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's working yeah so we're gonna
keep doing that we're going to push it
hard give it a whole lost two weeks it's
over laughing yeah I hope you guys have
your goal you know what to do
we're all doing this together as well so
this bus for it let's see how you guys
did let's see how I'm gonna did let's
see how much you lost
[Music]
you did it yeah man Cheers whoo how much
did you lose there about 22 kilograms
where's that bounce fifty thousand
Boeing feels like it the role waits for
the world is lifted I'd say not 22 so
yeah it's a lot now I picked up LaRon 20
liters the other day which is about the
size of it that's yeah yeah yeah that is
a lot yeah yeah so my wife as well she
did the children so you know she lost a
lot as well so we're both in a really
good place of yeah yeah Wow and yeah not
just that of just the white is there
healthy living as well yeah yes most
important I think changed yeah oh yeah
yeah but you feel happy right now
all right yeah I know I feel great but
the test is if hadna can keep on living
this healthy lifestyle so yeah this is
not the last video we're gonna come back
in six months and we're gonna see how
you are doing
yeah all right no that's a good idea cuz
hey I mean if you lose all that but we
gaining again and we're really going to
be the Biggest Loser yeah
because most people they do these diets
quick and then they lose weight but then
a few months later it's all bad and
that's what when we're gonna cut out so
that's the test right but let us know
what was it like going to work now with
your last weight and playing of the kids
yeah so you actually run around go swing
without having to put on there like a
bike muscle Batman suit so none playing
with the kids and rights I don't have to
say I will wait for me patches and stuff
and get out of bed I mean work is better
to focus mmm nice more energy yeah it's
it's crazy do you think where you were
yeah one bubbling sure did and that's
actually sad that thinking about it when
so long with all that fat omelet
basically killing yourself with all that
back fat
yeah all kinds of diseases and stuff
sterile but but not it's yeah holy whoa
mmm so he is the evidence even if you
have five kids if you have a job five to
eight and actually he had to work
double-time for the last few months he
still made the lifestyle change so
subscribe click the notification bell so
you won't miss the next video where
we're gonna come back in six months and
we're gonna see how you did if you kept
to this whole healthy lifestyle change
and let us know how you guys did and the
comments below
yeah we'd love to hear from you guys
that's it right yeah chin guys